all right the flaming garbage fire that
his American politics continues to flame
away and Al Franken has been caught in
the blaze plus we will talk about the
latest with Roy Moore and Bob Menendez
his jury is deadlocked so the news comes
fast and furious and crappy I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
here's that shot an airplane where
somebody says the bleep hits the fan and
there's actually a picture of poop
hitting fan and that's pretty much every
day in American politics now when I say
that it's a garbage fire I mean that
outside this door is a raging dumpster
fire and the smell just wafts through
the building and that is coming directly
from Washington DC and from Hollywood
and it's just all garbage and everyone
is garbage and that's the sort summary
of today's show but there's much more so
let's talk about all of the breaking
news but first I want to say thank you
to our sponsors over at filter by so you
know you you don't think about the air
quality in your home until Wednesday
there's black mold on your ceiling and
you're dying that's why you need to go
to filter by okay at my house we hadn't
thought about our filters we looked at
our filters that they were all dirty
they were all terrible and so we went to
it we measured our filters and we saw
which ones we needed the one to filter
by comm they send you the size you need
within 24 hours plus free shipping they
use double the industry standard Merv
rating on most filter sizes all of their
filters are manufactured right here in
the United States and they can ship any
size and in any quantity say 5% when you
set up auto delivery I never think about
air filters again that's why I like the
the auto delivery option because it
means that you're never gonna have to
worry about all of the filters arriving
you never have to worry about forgetting
about it for five years and then you
look at it and it's completely black go
to filter by dot-com today and get the
best price on top quality filters
shipped within 24 hours plus free
shipping filter by dot Konig and that's
filter by common we accept that auto
delivery you get 5% off filter by
dot-com it's very easy things just do it
and forget about it and make sure that
your your family is safe because air
quality is linked to health again filter
by comm all right so I do have a big
announcement coming momentarily about my
speech tour and no it's not like a big
announcement like Trump's big
announcement about his Asian tour which
was basically him announcing which
Chinese restaurants he'd eaten out in
China it's actually a really big
announcement we'll do that in just a
moment but first the news so the news
today
Al Franken likes Graham
big boobs really like this is the news
today so Al Franken is now being accused
by an LA anchor namely aunt Whedon she's
on KBC she tweeted on Thursday morning
that inspired by representative Jackie
Speier a Democrat who encouraged anyone
who had been victimized by a member of
Congress to step forward she decided to
tell her story in an essay published on
KB C's website according to daily
wire.com Sweden described her encounter
with Al Franken the senator from
Minnesota the man who is supposedly the
new conscience of the Senate yesterday
he was ripping up justice Don Willett
the Texas Supreme Court justice Don
Willett ripping him up and down because
Texas justice Don Willett who is very
funny on Twitter and once tweeted
something about how he wanted to
legalize marriage to bacon because he
liked bacon so much and Al Franken
thought that this was a slap at the gay
community somehow which is weird because
gay people aren't bacon but in any case
now Frank and apparently sexually
harassed slash assaulted Lea and
tweeting she said in an essay she
describes her encounter with Franken
whom she says used comedy as an excuse
to be inappropriate because comedians in
Hollywood apparently are all in
appropriate from louis c.k to David
Letterman tweeting a former model was on
her ninth tour with the USO and expected
to be the event emcee but quickly
discovered that Franken had penned a
special skit for her to perform with him
and he'd included a kiss that he
insisted they practiced beforehand so
here is the here is the actual essay
quote he repeated that actors really
need to rehearse everything and that we
must practice the kiss I said okay so he
would stop badgering me we did the line
leading up to the kiss and then he came
at me put his hand on the back of my
head mashed his lips against mine and
aggressively stuck his tongue in my
mouth hey first of all you know that is
sexual assault but I will say that every
actor in Hollywood has apparently done
this to every actress in Hollywood but
talk to any actress in this town you'll
see this is a very common occurrence
this is not letting Al Franken off the
hook by any means it's just to show you
that in Hollywood this stuff is soup
really prevalent he said I mean she says
I immediately pushed him away
with both of my hands against his chest
and told him if he ever did that to me
again I wouldn't be so nice about it the
next time I walked away all I could
think about was getting to a bathroom as
fast as possible to rinse the taste of
him out of my mouth okay she said she
didn't report frankenz behavior or the
alleged assaults to superiors but did
her best to stay out of frankenz way the
rest of the tour he repaid her she says
my pepper ignore with insults and drunk
devil horns on pictures she signed for
the troops then on the fly
home as Sweden slept in her kevlar vest
and helmet she says Franken groped her
while he posed for this photo yeah there
is there is a senator from Minnesota
groping or attempting to grope a
sleeping woman just all classes is
Senator Al Franken and she says I
couldn't believe me I couldn't believe
it he groped me without my consent while
I was asleep I felt violated all over
again
embarrassed belittled humiliated how's
there anyone grab my breasts like this
and think it's funny I told my husband
everything that happened and showed him
the picture she claimed she was too
scared to complain worried about the
potential backlash and possibility that
lobbing a sexual harassment allegation
against a famous comedian but every
percussionist sort of career which it
would the way that it works in Hollywood
because Hollywood is a scummy place is
that if you complain about sexual
harassment no one will hire you ever
again
this is reality and it's horrifying this
is it's it's really disgusting you're
considered a hard to put up with you're
considered somebody who doesn't get it
and isn't cool in Hollywood if you don't
put up with men acting like pervs or
anyone acting like a Purvis I'm gonna
grow up seonyu and you say anything
about it this makes you a prude in
Hollywood seriously Al Franken has now
responded to the allegations saying he
sends his sincerest apologies and the
photo was quote clearly intended to be
funny oh boy he says I certainly don't
remember the rehearsal for this getting
the same way but I send my sincerest
apologies to Leanne as to the photo was
clearly intended to be funny but wasn't
I shouldn't have done it
Al Franken is in serious poopoo now he's
in serious trouble we're about to find
out whether Democrats are flaming
hypocrites because they of course have
been calling for Roy Moore to be
expelled from the Senate if he were
elected and forever Republicans distance
themselves from Roy Moore the the Senate
Republican from Alabama quick correction
on make on the show so I keep saying for
the last two days the snot has addled my
brain from this cold I kept saying that
Richard Burr was the senator from
Alabama it's Richard Shelby of course in
any case the Democrats have been calling
for for Roy Moore to step down anyone
who does not call for Roy Moore to step
down is obviously is obviously
horrifying but are they saying the same
things about Al Franken well we know
that several of the several of the
Senators have been running away from
questions about this they they've been
legitimately like running from the press
and that makes perfect sense because
none of this matters to the you if it's
a member of your own political party
right it's in there's a bunch of
sascha stone is is a writer over I guess
Awards daily and she said sorry but if
what said but but if what Al Franken is
doing that photo with sexual harassment
we're gonna need a bigger boat come on
people snap out of it if someone did
this to my wife I'd punch them in the
face
how's that yeah I think this is a pretty
good standard right I think I think this
is a good standard for sexual harassment
/ sexual assault if someone's did this
to your wife would you punch them in the
face if you're a dude or if you're a
girl would you feel like you should
punch them in the face if the answer is
yes then it's probably I feel like
that's it
that's a pretty good standard so jeanne
shaheen right the Democrat from New
Hampshire she said quote I'm a member of
the Ethics Committee so I can't comment
oh-ho-ho-ho-ho so I guess this is how
it's gonna go now right women Democratic
women not quite standing by other women
I guess I'd heard that that Gillibrand
says that quote she so now Kirsten
Gillibrand has said that the allegations
against Franklin Franken are deeply
disturbing since she believes the woman
who accused him it's it's pretty
astonishing stuff this is the state of
American politics now so I have a
proposal to fix all of this it's
actually two proposals so proposal
number one is that we should actually
just have all the Congress people stay
home I think the remote voting is the
best solution to this so all of these
senators should be forced to live in the
districts from which they spring and
live at home with their wives and their
husbands this is the way that the sexual
harassment would I think be minimized
not because these people aren't scumbags
when they're in their home district but
because Washington DC is a scummy place
filled with scummy people but the other
way we can do this is it's time for I
think robot Congress so I think we need
to elect robots to Congress maybe that's
a little extreme but in any case we will
see whether the Democrats are giant
hypocrites or whether the Democrats are
not giant hypocrites in very very short
order obviously some are and some aren't
what's funny about this is the Democrats
really don't have any risk in getting
rid of Franken if they get rid of
Franken the governor of Minnesota right
now is Democrat still appoint a
replacement probably somebody like keith
ellison who is in absolute anti-semite
to watch against from the more say Al
Franken in the Senate politically if Al
Franken is replaced so Democrats are not
much to worry about by Mat Iglesias is
logic yesterday at voxcom
they have no excuse not to get rid of
him I do also want to do this flashback
because you're seeing a lot of Democrats
these days talk about how the Clintons
should go
you know it's time for Bill Clinton to
go and and now they're all hot and
bothered about sexual harassment I am
excited I will say this I'm excited that
Roy Moore is now forcing all Democrats
to be consistent about sexual harassment
right this is the only reason why
they're pretending to care about
offering and I don't think they deeply
care about Al Franken they certainly
didn't care about Bill Clinton being
disgusting piece of garbage until the
last five minutes or so this is the last
year I believe Joy Behar saying that
Bill Clinton's accusers were tramps on
national television I wonder if she
missed the opportunity to address it in
a way that the public would understand
that that's just not how you behave yeah
I would like to apologize to those
tramps that have slept with my husband's
okay so she's calling all of them tramps
right this is until the last five
minutes now it's believed the women
believe women the only reason the
Democrats are saying this of course they
want Roy Moore gone the network's if you
remember during the last election cycle
when Donald Trump brought up all of the
accusers against Bill Clinton the
network's attacked Trump for having the
temerity to bring up these accusers
Donald Trump proving nothing is
off-limits dramatically intensifying his
attacks on former President Bill
Clinton's history with women I looked at
the New York Times are they gonna
interview Juanita Broderick are they
gonna interview Paula Jones are they
gonna interview Kathleen Willey in one
case it's about exposure in another case
that's about groping and fondling and
touching against the woman's will and
rape and rape the rape accusation is
decades old and discredited TRADOC
settlements massive settlement $850,000
lots of other things they were referring
to a trio of women who say Bill Clinton
made unwanted sexual advances in the 80s
and 90s mr. Clinton denies it two of the
cases were plagued by factual
discrepancies still the accusations
linger and will be a focus of GOP ads
against Hillary Clinton's okay so look
how the media was downplaying all this
until two seconds ago when Bill
Clinton's dessicated political body was
thrown right under that train because
now it's time to get Republicans really
amazing how this happened el isn't if
inadvertently we end up raising our
standards for politicians because
everybody is so focused on getting rid
of the other guy that they're forced to
abide by their own standards maybe
something good comes out of this maybe
we actually all
new standards I don't think that's
what's going to happen though I think
that this will be a five-minute break
from from partisan politics dominating
and then we'll go right back to being
terrible about electing terrible people
I mean remember Democrats were so insane
back in the nineties over this thing
that Bill Clinton who was a perjurer and
a sexual molester and Bill Clinton was
applauded by Democrats after he was
impeached Democrats came to the White
House and they gave him a standing
ovation I asked the American people to
move with me
to go on from here the rise of other
rancor to overcome the pain and division
to be a repairer of the breach all of us
to make this country as one America what
it can and must be for our children in
the new century about to dawn thank you
very much there's literally after he was
impeached by the house right they're all
standing there clapping for him yeah the
reason that I bring this up is not what
about ISM I'm hung for one more to step
down on Fox News yesterday I said that
Roy Moore should step down on Fox and
Friends right so president Trump's
favorite show I said directly on that
show that that Roy Moore should
absolutely step down from his from his
Senate run so there's not what and what
about ISM only applies if you say that
you're excusing Roy Moore's behavior
because of Bill Clinton the reason that
I'm bringing up Bill Clinton is because
I believe that the standard for American
politicians was set in the 1990s and
that has been the consistent standard
all the way until now and so if
Democrats want to get rid of Roy Moore
and this is gonna force them to get rid
of Al Franken to good good now with all
of that said I do think that we should
be careful about what exactly are the
standards for sexual harassment and
sexual assault like we should have a
picture of Al Franken
you know purporting to grab a woman's
breasts while she's sleeping that's a
pretty bad stuff I want to make sure
that the allegations that we see are
credible the reason that I said that
more is I mean that picture as a pig I
mean come on there's a picture for you
but if it but the reason that I've said
that Roy Moore should step down is
because the allegations are credible I
went when Ted Cruz for example during
his campaign was accused to have slept
with a bunch of his campaign aides the
allegations were not credible because
there was no there are no names that
were named all of the libman denied it
there was not any there was not any
corresponding information but there was
I remember during the campaign there was
a rape allegation that the media were
not widely reporting against Donald
Trump and
because the accusers story basically
fell apart pretty quickly so the
allegations have to be credible but with
that said you know that I think that if
we're gonna if our new standard is the
credible allegations are treated as we
don't want these people anywhere near
the levers of power I think that's a
good thing maybe inadvertently we'll
stumble into something better here okay
so before I go any further and I do have
a big announcement about my my College
lecture tour in just a moment first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at Birch gold so right now if it
feels like the economy is is doing
really well but it still feels like it
might be a little bit inflated and you
think that maybe the stock market's
gonna take a dive sometime in here if
you are concerned that there are some
there's gonna be some shock to the real
estate market if or if you just want to
hedge your bet that's why it's time to
buy some precious metals go over to
birchgold.com slash bend and they'll
give you a comprehensive 16 page kit
showing how gold and silver can protect
your savings how you can legally move
your IRA or 401k out of risky stocks and
bonds and into a precious metals IRA
Birch gold group they belong standing
track record of continued success
thousands of satisfied clients countless
five-star reviews an A+ rating with the
Better Business Bureau contact Birch
gold group right now to request a free
information kit on physical precious
metals again that's birchgold.com /ban
we've had them on the show they're the
people that I trust with precious metals
investment ask all your questions make
sure you feel secure and then get
precious metals as part of your
portfolio birchgold.com slash button
okay so here's the big announcement that
I've been teasing a little bit here so
my college tour is ramping up next year
we've spoken up 3035 college campuses
over the last couple of years and now
I'm announcing that we are partnering
exclusively with young America's
Foundation they sponsored many of my
campus tours for my 2018-2019 campus
tour and thanks to Fred Allen who is one
of the who's the biggest sponsor for
this a lot of students who have wanted
to host an event but lacked the
necessary funding they're being granted
that funding by yeah yeah and their vast
u network continue to plan engaging
campus events and they are we don't have
a process for this so because we receive
so many requests every single day I mean
literally dozens of requests every
single day and because of how many off
receives on their end we've now been
setting to working to set up a formal
application process so for all the
college students who want to bring me
going live today there's an application
and info page at yah org slash Ben
Shapiro tour that's yah org slash Ben
Shapiro tour we lay out all the
necessary steps and info needed to a
Horner
to order a request hosting and event
because of my crazy schedule we're
actually limiting next year's tour to 12
campuses so be fast about this be sure
to follow all the steps in the
application and presents a good proposal
for I you think your school should be
one of the twelve checkout yeah org
slash ben shapiro toward the TF Torrance
slash Ben Shapiro tour to submit an
application and that will allow us to
get back to you faster as well okay so
meanwhile while all of this is going on
in the Senate the the continuing saga of
Roy Moore continues apace and I want to
talk about some of the solutions to Roy
Moore saga but one of the things that
one of the things I find really kind of
gross about the way that that sexual
allegations are treated its gross on on
in two aspects one is that sexual
allegations without any other
corroborating proof if you if you say
show me some corroborating evidence
people go nuts and if you say there is
corroborating evidence now you have to
show me why it's not true people go nuts
so there's no solution right Roy Morris
lawyers put out a defense yesterday that
was so weak and so strained and yet
people are hanging their hat on this peg
I remember that during the during the
campaign there are some of this with
regard to President Trump and I remember
with Bill Clinton there was some of the
same sort of stuff with regard to Trump
I recall that there was an allegation
that Trump had sexually assaulted a
woman on a plane and people were going
back and trying to figure out when the
arms the armrest on that kind of a kind
of plane went up or down and this was
supposed to be used as proof that Trump
had never done any of this I'm seeing
something similar happening with with
Roy Moore the question you have to ask
yourself is whether these allegations
are credible now you can still make the
case and I'm getting letters from people
in Alabama who are saying listen I'm not
gonna vote for Doug Jones I don't want
you to vote for Doug Jones I didn't vote
for Hillary Clinton right I thought that
Donald Trump was kind of ass cause I
didn't vote for Hillary Clinton I'm not
saying you have to vote for dog Jones
I'm saying now is the time for all of
you folks to be planning a write-in
campaign for somebody who is not
credibly accused of child molestation is
that a terrible idea is that a horrible
idea yeah I didn't vote at the top of
the ticket I think it's possible to do
that too I understand why you don't want
to talk Jones in the Senate I don't want
him in the Senate either I don't want a
pro-abortion Democrat in the Senate but
that does not mean that we got to brush
off accusations that are like this so
let's go through more lawyers defense
because this is this is pretty bad there
are a couple more allegations by the way
that more groped people there to new
accusers who are suggesting that more
was harassing them one of them was a
high school girl who said that when
Moore was in his 30s he called up her
high school pulled her out of trig class
to ask her on a date which it like
called the principal's office and said
can I speak to axe and the girl went to
the office and she said what's up and he
said I want to ask out his hey what are
you doing she said I haven't rigged
class right now okay in any case Morris
lawyer and let's say his legal team is
not the strongest and when I say not the
strongest I mean it's really quite
terrible like I don't know whether he
went to the his lawyers went to be my
cousin mini school of lawyering but they
don't have the street smarts of Joe
Pesci here is in this room okay in any
case here was hero's Roy Morris attorney
and then at a certain point you just
have to laugh at this stuff because we
are so down the rabbit hole folks I mean
we are we are in Alice in Wonderland and
here is here is Roy Moore's lawyer
yesterday trying to make excuses for Roy
Moore attempting to date girls who were
like 15 or 16 years old in Alabama in
1979 he's talking to a he's talking to a
an anchor on MSNBC and this anchor the
anchors name is Ali Velshi I guess and
and watch Ali Velshi I guess has some
background that he thinks that he can
discern because Ali bet she's a brown
person and this does not go well from
Roy Moore's lawyer but point is these
countries you have to do with dating a
14 year old I'm not finished with the
context of it what is Ali Velshi
background have to do with dating under
children fourteen-year-old girls sure in
other in other countries there's
arrangement through parents for what we
would first an eventual marriage and
ours also definite but here's the
answered question
Ali's from Canada and Canada they have a
real record of people trying to hit up
14 year olds I love that Ali's brown
therefore Ali must be from a country
where child marriage is the thing by the
way there are countries where child
marriages thing they're not civilized
Western countries like my wife's
grandmother was married I think when she
was 13 I think the story about her is is
that she went out and played jump rope
at her wedding like that's not good okay
like it worked out in the long run but
this is why Western civilization is a
superior place ok Western civilization
is a wonderful place because we don't
have 30 year old men who are trying to
knock up fourteen-year-old girls so
Moore's lawyers not doing a particularly
wonderful job and then in last night
that or the night before last night you
remember Sean Hannity on Fox News
basically gave a 24 hour ultimatum to
Roy Moore and the the ultimatum was I
need you to credibly show me why these
accusations are false or you need to get
out of the race so Roy Moore sent an
open letter to Sean Hannity and the open
letter is not particularly good so the
open letter says dear Sean I am
suffering the same treatment other
Republicans of hadrons were a month
prior to the general election for US
Senate in Alabama I've been attacked by
The Washington Post and other liberal
media in a desperate attempt to smear my
character and defeat my campaign and
then he talks at length about how
wonderful he has he repeats that he's
been married for a long time and has
grandkids etc etc and then he says we
are on the in the process of
investigating these false allegations to
determine their origin and motivation
for instance we had documented that the
most recent accuser Beverly Nelson was a
party in a divorce action before me in
Etowah County Circuit Court in 1999 no
motion was made for me to recuse ok so
there's a problem with this particular
allegation by Roy Moore which is that
the actual judge who was assigned to
this case was not Roy Moore Roy Moore
signed I think one document at the very
very end of the case she never sat in a
courtroom with Roy Moore apparently in
her accusations Nelson's do not mention
I was the judge assigned to her in the
divorce case in 1999 because he wasn't
apparently a matter that apparently
caused her no distress at a time those
18 years closer to the alleged assault
yet 18 18 years later while talking
before the cameras about the supposed a
dassault she seemingly could not contain
her emotions and shows my signature on
the order of dismissal in the divorce
case was annotated with the letters da
representing the initials of my court
assistant well again one of the problems
is that apparently his actual court
assistants of record did not have those
initials at that time so very weak
defense from judge Roy Moore in this
letter to to Sean Hannity trying to
convince him not to throw him and not to
throw him overboard
and then he trotted out and then he
trotted out his lawyers to say that the
signature in the yearbook is fraud
remember we played the the tape of the
signature in the yearbook the accuser
showing the signature in the aerbook
from Roy Moore and then his attorney
said it was a fraud I'm gonna show you
the tape of the attorney again I don't
know where he's getting his legal team
it looks like he's getting them from one
of the the ambulance-chasing firms that
you see advertising on television but
before we get there first I wanna say
thank you to this awesome new advertiser
really I'm very excited about this new
advertiser man crates calm like a new
these these folks are awesome so this is
not a cheese of the Month Club or a new
tie they offer a hundred hand curated
gift collections for every type of guy
this is perfect for Christmas or
Hanukkah from the rugged outdoorsman to
the sports fanatic and everything in
between they have the whiskey
appreciation crate with a personalized
to cancer and glasses for your favorite
drink or the grillmaster crate with
brass knuckle meat tenderizer like
little red brass knuckles and cast-iron
smoker box go-to man crates con picked
the perfect crate choose the delivery
date and then here's the best part of it
when the crate arrives they send you a
laser engraved crowbar and you
legitimately pry open the crate with
your bare hands and the crowbar in order
to get at the product which is just
awesome it's super fun I just got a bass
phone one I believe go-to man crates
calm slash pens get 5% off your order
that's 5% off at man crates dot-com
slash Bend that's man crates dot-com /
Ben I mean nothing like making a city
boy feel like a real man like prying
open a crate that has two cancer's
inside but that's a I seriously I'm
gonna make my wife get me one of these
they're pretty amazing and they have a
wide variety of these products that are
just awesome a sports themed products
those are the ones that I like and I
just got ones with them there's a poker
themed product so there's nothing
there's nothing more James Bond then you
get a crate in the mail you pry it open
and it's poker chips just awesome so man
crates calm / Ben and that will let them
know that we sent you as well you get
five percent off of your order okay so
here is the Roy Moore's lawyer saying
the signature is a fraud a fraud here we
go so right now trend Garmin our
attorney has sent a letter or is sending
a letter to Gloria Allred demanding that
the yearbook be released there are a
couple things that you need to look at
look
the 1977 after Merry Christmas look at
those two sevens and then look below at
the 77 and I want to ask you do you
think it was written by the same person
I want you to look at Old Hickory house
which they say Judge Moore wrote judge
Moore says there's no way in the world
that's his handwriting okay so now we're
gonna go into handwriting analysis which
is really a pretty pretty weird form of
analysis like it's always very
questionable and so then just to make
things worse Gloria Allred as I said
before Gloria Allred is not the most
credible human okay and the and the fact
that Gloria Allred continues to be part
of this case does not help anybody so
Gloria Allred is asked okay so why don't
you turn over the yearbook to some
neutral third party Authority she says
I'll turn over to the Senate and then
she's asked is the is the allegation
that this was forged real or not and she
refuses tans for that question which is
just granting flame to the fire which is
what el Allred wants by the way the real
reason that Gloria Allred is doing this
is not because this is some sort of
tacit admission that the yearbook is a
fake okay the reason that she is doing
this is because she wants the Senate
hearing so she can grandstand and she's
gonna do anything possible to get the
Senate hearing so she can grandstand
that's what's going on here with Gloria
Allred we will allow all of this to be s
and answered at hearings but that's not
a flat denial Oh Gloria well it's all
I'm saying is we're not denying we're
not admitting we're not addressing we
will not be distracted and we will
pursue a just result for our client okay
thank you gloria allred for throwing
more gasoline on the flames of
conspiracy theories we're gonna have
Sheriff Joe Arpaio actually creates an
investigatory committee after they
figure out whether Obama was indeed born
in Kenya and the birth certificate is a
fake we're gonna find out also whether
this yearbook was actually signed in
Kenya by Ted Cruz's father after
murdering JFK I'm very excited to find
all of this out all of this is just so
but but here's what's happening so
because all you have to do now in order
to doubt an allegation is basically
throw any sort of doubt out there
so now Moore is trying to turn this into
in a lot of zoella's they're trying to
turn this into if you don't support Roy
Moore it's because you're a kook if you
don't support Roy Moore
because you're a weakling it's cuz
you're a pansy and you just want to see
the Senate seat lost I'm not the one
losing the Senate seat right now dude
you're the one losing the Senate seat
hey the NRS SI released a poll I don't
quite believe it it says the Doug Jones
is up 12 points I don't think that's
right but this is a much closer race
than it should be Larry Sabato just
moved into the lean Democrat column in a
state that votes 6633 Republican so you
know the only person who's losing a race
here is Roy Moore not me can I want to
run more out so that Republicans can win
this race but in any case his supporters
are out there saying that if you don't
support remorse because you're a bunch
of sissies you're a bunch of girls
here's an Alabama pastor saying just
this in the name of God you're a
if you don't support a guy credibly
accused of child molestation I was
everyone all these people silent for so
many decades only to all come forth at
the same time now
well perhaps satanically motivated but
politically carried out with it's funny
it's funny how the Republican Party is
what a bunch of sissies the Democrats
rally around their candidates even when
they're guilty Republicans want to throw
them under the bus on a mere accusation
without going whether they're guilty or
not okay Noah this is one of the
arguments that I keep hearing is
Democrats don't throw their people on
bus they rally around them first of all
we'll see what they do with Al Franken
second of all just because someone else
does something bad doesn't mean you
should and it's not like Republicans can
get away with this and the same way
Democrats can you know why because we
have moral standards this is one of the
things I've always said about being a
Democrat it's very easy to be a Democrat
because when you have no moral standards
in social life that means that you can
get away with just about anything when
you say that social standards matter
that social fabric matters that morality
matters of course we hold you to a
different standard of course we do now I
don't think that that should necessarily
be the case in the everyone should be
held to the same standard regardless as
to whether you embrace the standard but
when you do embrace the standard the
added charge of hypocrisy is gonna be
thrown at you when you move away from it
okay so so Roy Moore himself is trying
to turn this into a battle about Mitch
McConnell this is something that you see
Steve Benton wants to do also he you
know in order to avoid the allegations
I've been saying up for three days
they've been trying to turn this into
this is about McConnell it's not about
McConnell I don't like McConnell okay
I've been ripping on McConnell for years
look back at everything I've written
about McConnell the only thing McConnell
has done right is get these judges
through that's really great it really is
he
he held up he held up the the
appointment of the of the Democrat whose
name now escapes me the Democrat judge
who who was appointed by by Barack Obama
he held that up until the until Trump
could be elected and that's how he got
judge Gorsuch that was goodbye Mitch
McConnell but otherwise I'm not a big
big big Mitch McConnell fan but this is
about McConnell but Judge Roy Moore
tweeted out yesterday did as though as
though Mitch McConnell the only one
going after him Zera Mitch McConnell
bring it on and what he neglected was
the second part of the tweet is my
favorite movie and I think we can we all
know why it was his favorite movie
actually the best squad around for years
but nobody's been able to see what we
can do we're in trouble
but you better believe all that's gonna
change is here you wanna make it right
then when you go to Nationals bring it
up bring it
and then remorse actually in the
background for some reason he was there
at the filming I don't know why okay in
any case in any case here are the
solutions so there a bunch of options
that have been presented judge more
bring it on guys we had a joke about
this otherwise this time is so dark and
so terrible there's an article from the
Babylon bee which is a Christian
oriented parody site that said pull half
of evangelicals say that they would vote
for Satan to stop Doug Jones I think
that's not entirely untrue I mean 100
percent of Democrats would vote for
Satan to stop any Republican basically
in any case I would like to let's lay
out the options as to where we go from
here none of the options are good
they're really three options that are
being weighed right now so option one is
the Sean Hannity option so after Sean
lays out this very strong case a couple
of nights ago that Roy Moore has to come
up with something credible or Sean's
gonna call from to get out of the race
Roy Moore basically offers nothing and
then Sean says we'll let the people
decide which is a cop-out okay like I
like Sean personally I find Sean
everyone who knows Sean likes Sean Sean
is a really sweet solid guy but this is
a cop-out okay jj-just is in my opinion
so serious the people of Alabama they
need to know the truth and they've got
to have all the facts that they need and
that means that the Alabama voters can
make an educated informed inclusive
decision for their state when they go to
the polls and if that means whatever it
means to get to the truth of it means
more time I believe the governor
according to Gregg Jarrett has the
ability to make that decision
the Alabama people deserve that Gregg
Jarrett said the governor can delay the
race if need be now the people of
Alabama deserve to have a fair choice
especially in light of the new
allegations tonight now we have told you
everyone's point of view the accusers
continue to have an open invitation to
come on this show and share their story
at the end of the day I want to tell you
something I lived in Alabama I enjoyed
my time in Alabama and I know these
people they're smart they're great
Americans God family faith country and I
am very confident that when everything
comes out they will
make the best decision for their state
okay so that's a giant cop-out so I've
told you listen everyone knows this is
when people say people will vote how
people will vote of course that's true
of course that's true
but I tell you what I think right I
think we're way more did it and I think
that you should either write in a
candidate or you should not vote at all
okay this is my these are my options
right this is what I think you'll still
do what you want to do right for an
Alabama you'll do it you're you're
you're a grown-up you make your own
decisions but I'll give you my opinion
for Sean and to basically back out of
giving an opinion here I think is I do
think it's it's a real cop-out I don't
like heading Sean I like I like Sean but
it's but it's a it's a cop-out and yeah
okay so option two so the option one is
let the vote happen okay and then more
wins or he loses if he loses then Zell
Jones takes the seat and this is a real
problem for Republicans who now have 51
seats in the Senate as opposed to 52
they can't even get a tax bill through
right now I'm gonna talk about that in a
second okay option two would be to
somehow reset the election so there are
two options here in with an option to
resetting the election one is the one
that you saw Sean mentioned there which
is the governor could theoretically
delay the election very difficult to do
that very difficult to see how it matter
actually if you delayed the election or
she sorry if she delayed the election
it's very difficult to see how that
would necessarily impact the election
also it sets a pretty bad precedent that
anytime something bad happens for the
candidate of your political party you
just delay the election obviously if a
Democrat did that on the flip side we
would be ragingly upset over it the
other thing is that Mitch McConnell is
is is considering a gambit so Luther
strange who's the current occupant of
the seat his term expires remember he
was appointed to fill jeff Sessions a
seat and sort of corrupt fashioned his
term expires in a couple of years or
rather next year I believe and therefore
they are holding the special election on
that basis so one of the considerations
here is that if loses their strange
instead of filling out the rest of his
term resigns right now that triggers a
new special election now that's
questionable right under the 17th
amendment to the Constitution the way
that Senate seats are filled is that
when there is a Namba that when there is
a in absence of vacancy then the
governor fills that and then a new
election is declared so does it matter
if the if the guy who filled that
vacancy resigns it early not really
clear for them the 17th amendment but
this is the logic that maybe they can
get away with it
maybe they can just reset the election
have a new special election the new
prime
and everything so the problem with this
of course is that Roy Moore could very
easily win those primaries and Roy what
would end up happening I guess we could
do this out in for an item I guess you
could have Luther strange basically
resigns triggering a new special
election in the meantime you see the
Jeff Sessions is appointed by the
governor and which point Roy Moore wins
the primaries at which point Jeff
Sessions resigns at which point a new
election is called at which point she
appoints Luther strange
at which point Roy more wins the
primaries and we can do this forever
it'll be lit just like inception will be
four levels deep and Leonardo DiCaprio
will be wandering around on the sand
forgetting where he came from an old man
filled with regret we can do any of
these things I guess but I'm not sure
that it's actually gonna work finally
there is option three
okay this is he don't seat him option so
Kristin Gillibrand the Democrat from New
York she says that this will be the move
that if the Roy Moore were actually
elected to the Senate there be an ethics
hearing and then there would be a move
not to seat him I think there will be a
outcry of members of the Senate who do
not want him to serve even if he's
elected I believe these survivors I
think most people do and I think it's
important that he be held accountable
but hopefully the people in his date
will vote for someone else okay so
Gillibrand my the way said she supports
an investigation into the Franken
allegations but she's not calling for
Franken to step down so she's she wants
more out but Franken Wow we'll have an
ethics investigation an ethics
investigation just means nothing ever
happens because there are tons of ethics
investigations whew and with expulsion
but the question is should Republicans
seat more so yesterday I said on
national television I don't think they
should see more and I got some blowback
from that people were upset about that
and even some folks who are I was
talking about off the air I was talking
with a couple of folks off the air who
are on the show with me and they were
saying well wouldn't that be
disrespecting the people of Alabama's
choice and my view is so what okay and I
know that's the sort of harsh language
but the idea here is that democracy is
not the same as living in a republic and
I'm gonna discuss this in the big idea
in just a second listen I don't want to
play with fire where everybody is now
expelled it overruling the will of the
people I don't think that's something
that we should take lightly but I'm not
taking this lightly when you have
credible allegations of child
molestation I don't think that that's
taking it lightly I do think that the
reason the founders put in place checks
and balances including the ability to
expel a member or not seat a member was
for situations like this I do think that
that exists and the big idea in a little
while I'm gonna talk about the
difference between living in a democracy
and living in a republic and why it is
that the founders were not supremely
comfortable with the argument that just
because the people want something that
people ought to get something I'll talk
about that in just a second I also want
to talk about the bob menendez juried
ziz is apparently deadlocked again
according to CNN the jury says it is
deadlocked on all charges and the
defense wants to declare a mistrial it's
a seven woman five man jury they say
they are deadlocked and they said they
were deadlocked on Monday on Thursday
they said they've reviewed all the
evidence slowly and they're not willing
to change their positions and he still
want the judge still wants them to go
back to the drawing board he's facing
charges of conspiracy bribery bribery
and honest services fraud relating to
abusing the power of his office it could
carry decades in prison
the prosecutors say that he accepted
more than six hundred grand in political
contributions at luxurious hotel suite
at the Park Hyatt and Paris free rides
on a private jet from wealthy
ophthalmologist solomon Megan Megan in
exchange for political favors including
getting visas from elgin's hot
girlfriends so all of that is is
breaking news as well we'll talk about
all that but first you're gonna have to
go over to daily wired.com and subscribe
at daily wire.com you can subscribe for
99999 a month and get the rest of our
show live on video you can get the rest
of michael Noel's show live on video and
andrew Clavin show live on video be part
of our mailbag the shapiro store is
launching in short order we've got it
all set up it's just that the gear is
taking a little while to get set for the
store but that will be up very shortly
and you'll get discounts for that when
you become a member also for $99 a year
you get the annual membership and that
comes along with this the very greatest
in all beverage vessels this beverage
muscle the reason that I continue to be
sick is I haven't been drinking enough
from this beverage vessel the rumor is
that it cures disease I can't verify
that that's not that sound the FDA
approved claim but all I can say is that
the rumor is the rumor is that if you
pour this over Sean Connery's wounds if
he's been shot then they immediately
heal this is just what I hear in many
cases leftist here's hot or cold tumblr
you get that for 99 dollars a year and
you get all the rest of that good stuff
too plus you just want to listen later
go over to YouTube make sure that you
subscribe go over to SoundCloud and
iTunes make sure that you subscribe
there as well we are the largest
to score and conservative podcast in the
nature
[Music]
all righty so you know I know a lot of
people aren't tight with me for talking
so much about the more thing but I do
think this is a moral breaking point for
the Republican Party because I don't
think that we can get away with the
vision of governance that we are
suggesting that we can know that we on
the right can elect characterless people
and get away with it because the whole
point of being on the right the whole
point of being on the right is that we
are supposed to stand for virtue this is
one of the things I'm writing about in
my new book I'm working on a new book
and the absence of virtue in political
life and in common life the decision
that we don't have to worry about virtue
or inculcation of virtue or have a
common definition of virtue this means
that we are less happy as people it
means we don't trust each other it means
we don't trust our neighbors you
wouldn't trust your neighbor but you
wouldn't trust Roy Moore to babysit your
child why would you trust for Roy Moore
to make your policy why would you trust
Roy Moore at the levers of the most
powerful government in the history of
humanity and these are you know I think
that we should be asking these questions
regardless if we have a right left or
Center and I've been very very
consistent on this okay time for some
things I like and then some epic things
I hate and a quick Big Idea so things I
like I was on the plane yesterday
lots of plane riding and and there is a
and there's a movie that I was able to
watch JetBlue by the way is spectacular
I just have to say JetBlue is great they
had free internet they had new movies
just tremendous service all the way
through and and I was able to watch this
this movie from Taylor Sharon and one of
my favorite directors hell or high water
and Sicario and the movies Wind River
and Jeremy Renner and elizabeth Olsen
Jeremy Renner is terrific elizabeth
Olsen is not but the movie itself is
that the movie itself is quite good the
last half-hour of it is is really tense
and spectacular it's very gritty okay
it's very upsetting there's there's one
team near the end where a crime is
replayed and it is very deep I mean it
is deeply upsetting so if you're not up
for that then you probably won't be up
for any of Taylor Sheridan's films but
that the movie itself is is effective
and an interesting and takes on some
issues with regard to Native
reservations Native American
reservations which which I think had
been long neglected is a place that
tremendous suffering goes on here's a
little bit of the trailer
[Music]
any emergency assistance the Wind River
Indian Reservation
I'm June banner FBI welcome to Wyoming
by yourself it's just me that's Cory
Lambert is where I found the body
most murders are never solved in in
native reservations essentially she's a
fighter
most criminals are never found it's it's
it's a very good movie and one of the
things that I like about this film and
one of the things I like about Taylor
Sheridan's writing generally is that not
only is he willing to do nuance but also
he doesn't do these anti-american
sucker-punches so one of the things
that's really nice about this film is
that it's all about investigation into a
woman's murder on a on a Native American
reservation but the person who's solving
the murder is a white guy jeremy renner
and this comes up right and he's not
portrayed as somebody who's married to a
Native American woman he's not portrayed
as like an unsympathetic white guy
walking onto a Native American
reservation and raping the place that's
not the idea the idea is that if we can
find our common humanity then we're
gonna be able to solve some problems
whereas if we steep ourselves in these
artificial divisions then we're never
gonna be able to solve these problems
like there's a couple of characters one
who's a Native American character who
sort of revels in his in the feeling of
victimization and jeremy renner give him
a nice lecture and then some white guys
who revel in the idea that they get to
victimize Native American girls and
they're the bad guys so I think that
it's I it's it's quite a good movie it's
it's worth watching again as I say
jeremy renner is very very good in it
elizabeth olsen is less good in it just
because she does wide-eyed the entire
film elizabeth blunt in Sicario gives a
much better performance than elizabeth
olsen does but the movie is worth seeing
okay it's not gonna get a lot of credit
by the way because it's a Weinstein
Company production and so it's it was
slate it was slated for some awards it
was one steam company produced and so
now it's probably gonna get ignored
because of the Weinstein which I find
just yeah I mean Weinstein didn't make
the movie put some money behind it I
don't think that just cuz Weinstein put
money behind something means the entire
everything you put money behind his
garbage I don't think that's right
okay other things that I like so this
was pretty funny yesterday Trump was
giving his speech he said he had a big
announcement when he came back from Asia
he did not have a big announcement he
announced basically all of the nice
hotels he'd visited and then he he took
a drink of water from a water bottle and
for a brief moment in time the internet
went insane Japanese companies have
announced investments in the United
States worth more than 8 billion dollars
17,000 jobs thank you they don't have
water that's okay
what but it goes drinking that water I
like to look into the camera the
steely-eyed glare as he tries to open
this bottle of water Japanese
manufacturers and everybody went nuts
for a second because Donald Trump and of
course mock Marco Rubio for drinking
from the bottle of water Rubio actually
he actually critiqued Trump on his water
bottle technique which is pretty funny
on Twitter so I thought that was kind of
funny okay time for some things that I
hate so as you know I love Twitter I'm
very very active on Twitter I have
almost a million followers there and I
tweet incessantly annoying everyone in
my feed and Twitter is now cracking down
on blue checkmarks the way they're doing
this is they're saying that they want to
get rid of blue checkmarks for people
who tweet controversial and nasty things
so they got rid of it for some white
supremacist like Richard Spencer and
Baked Alaska and here's my problem with
this I think all those people are
garbage but the blue checkmark is there
so that if somebody is imitating you
it's supposed to verify you right if the
idea is that if somebody is is imitating
you you can report them for imitating
you it's a protection against fraud
essentially fraud protections still
exist for bad people like if you want to
kick off Baked Alaska because you think
Baked Alaska is a scumbag and he
violates your Terms of Service bring a
white supremacist you know that's your
that's your standard you're you're a
private company can do you want but if
you're removing verification check marks
with that instant weather that
inherently is doing is now you're saying
that there are certain people whose
messages are approved who we will
continue to provide blue checkmarks and
there are certain people whose messages
are not approved we will not provide
blue checkmarks and now it looks like
Twitter is sponsoring certain messages
it's really dumb business more than
anything else I think Twitter's making a
huge mistake it's very stupid okay other
things that I hate this was an amazing
picture okay so I have to show you this
picture this was actually photographed
by a P and this was real this is Steve
minuchin and his wife Louise Linton okay
they went to that they they went over to
the US Mint and they they held up copies
of the first currency notes bearing his
and u.s. treasurer haveta Carranza
signatures at the Bureau of Engraving
and printing and I don't even know
what's going on here I mean like it's a
bit if you can't see the picture it's
manoosh
holding up the sheet and then his wife
Louise Linton in Cruella de Vil gloves
giving a Bond villain glare into the
camera as she smiles holding this up the
best tweet that I saw on this yesterday
was Louise Louise Linton with Louise
slit and with the things she loves and
Steve minuchin I thought that was pretty
good also the there's a picture of him
holding up the sheet and her smiling at
him while wearing apparently kylo ren's
costume from the last from the last Star
Wars movie it's pretty amazing you gotta
love Louise Linton for owning it but
yeah this is not a good look I mean you
don't want to look plutocratic that's
not exactly the best look the best look
which of course led to one of my
favorite things that I have ever seen
which is somebody made this video of
Steve minuchin and Steven action is
let's say he's a rather smarmy character
and Steve minuchin you have to laugh
they cut a video of Steve minuchin
talking but they filled his mouth with
gargling sounds and it really works it's
really funny was it appropriate that Tom
Price was fired you regret making the
requests you made for government
aircraft whether it was to go to
Kentucky I know there's an Inspector
General on that one secretary munition I
appreciate you coming on I don't know
why I bet it was funny it made me laugh
okay time for the big idea so I
mentioned earlier that if they don't
seat if they don't see Roy Moore after
he's elected is this is slap in the face
to the people of Alabama I think the
answer is no I think that the people of
Alabama many of them who would vote for
Roy Moore don't want him in the Senate
they just don't want Doug Jones there
and so if you were replaced by somebody
like Jeff Sessions I think that a lot of
people in Alabama would probably breathe
a sigh of relief I think a lot of
Alabama voters say I'm not voting for
Magellan's I don't want Jones in the
Senate I don't want the election to get
away I'll vote for more right them
they'll make the binary decision and
vote for more now that would be the
logic anyway and right and won't work so
we'll vote for him
he'll win and then maybe they'll replace
him so I think that does exist but
second of all there's this idea that is
going around I find it very irritating
that institution
that were specifically set up to check
public excesses are now considered out
of bounds it's terrible how dare you
check what the public lawns here okay
the founders never believed in democracy
the founders believed in republicanism
and found in fact the founders despise
the idea of direct democracy the idea
that the people know best in every
situation never crossed the founders
mind
okay here's what John Adams wrote in
1814 remember democracy never last long
it soon wastes exhaust and murders
itself there never was a democracy yet
that did not commit suicide
it is in vain to say that democracy is
less vain less proud at less selfish
less ambitious or less avaricious than
aristocracy or monarchy it is not true
in fact and nowhere appears in history
those passions are the same in all men
under all forms of simple government and
when unchecked produced the same effects
of fraud violence and cruelty when clear
prospects are open before vanity pride
avarice or ambition for their easy
gratification it is hard for the most
considerate philosophers and the most
conscientious more or less to resist the
temptation individuals have conquered
themselves nations and large bodies of
men never right so John Adams saying
listen it's a rectum ah Christine as you
the people always are right is not true
which is why you have a set of checks
and balances if you believe that people
are always right majority rule on
everything you would need a Constitution
you would need a set it you wouldn't
need a house you would need a presidency
you wouldn't need a judiciary you
wouldn't need checks and balances can
the Senate was given the authority as to
whether to seat particular senators
specifically for situations where
senators should not be seated even
though they were elected you know and
somebody yesterday asked me well what if
the electoral college had rogue electors
who voted against Donald Trump
what I said is that is what the
electoral college was designed to do I
would have disagreed that the electoral
college should have seen Donald Trump is
such a threat to democracy that wouldn't
see him but originally this is what the
electoral college was designed to do the
electoral college was designed to stop
bad men from entering high office or
women that's what it was designed to do
in fact if I had my druthers the
electoral college would have said nixed
to both of the candidates and then we
would have been able to see somebody
else in any case Chief Justice John
Marshall said the same thing he said
between a balanced Republican and
democracy the difference is that is like
that between order and chaos right we're
a balanced republic is designed to check
out the excesses James Madison writes
this in Federalist 10 which we'll get to
when we eventually get to Federalist 10
in our view the Federalist Papers I
think next week is Federalist 4 he says
democracies have ever been spectacles of
turbulence and contention
have ever been found incompatible with
personal security or the rights of
property and have in general been as
short in their lives as they are violent
in their deaths if we don't accept that
some checks and balances are necessary
to prevent the excesses of people who
feel forced into binary positions then
we're not going to be able to actually
see what the system of government was
meant to be okay so we will be back here
tomorrow with all the latest we'll see
if the Democrats continue to stand in
hypocritical fashion by Al Franken and
so we'll see if Bob Menendez walks free
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
[Music]